The United States is pursuing an imperial policy and Biden
declares that if Putin is not
stopped in Ukraine, then Russia
will attack NATO, this is complete nonsense. I think
that President Biden understands this, this is
just a figure of speech to
justify his erroneous policy in the
Russian direction, it is
erroneous.  because I don’t think that the
United States today,
bearing in mind the prospect of global
development, is as interested as they
thought 20 years ago in inflicting and
as they publicly declare a
strategic defeat of Russia, I don’t
think that this is in the national
interests of the States themselves, the president of any
large Country  NATO Country,
especially the only owner of NATO The United States
is the owner of NATO, this is their
backyard of the NATO Armed Forces or the entire NATO organization
that Russia has no massacres, no
interest, no geopolitical interest, neither
economic nor political, not
military, to fight with NATO countries, so they
dragged Finland into NATO from us
there were some disputes with Finland All
disputes, including those of a territorial
nature in the middle of the 10th century, were all resolved long ago
on the kindest,
most cordial
economic relations were in development. Yes,
there were some problems in the Forestry complex, but they
were connected with the need to develop
timber processing within the country  Well, all
this is nonsense, a trifle, in fact there
were no problems now, there will be because we
will now create the Leningrad
Military District there and concentrate
certain military
units there. Why do they need this, some kind of nonsense